- What could we expect from Season Two
from Saved by the Bell?
- I mean...
- Which, did you watch?
I watched Saved by the Bell,
and I'm a lot older than you, so.
- Yeah, no.
I - I wasn't, you know, I wasn't around
- I don't think alive or maybe...
- (indistinct).
I don't even think I was a thought.
Well, I definitely wasn't a thought.
I kind of just was a surprise, there.
But that's a story for a different time.
But no, I mean,
the show is like a satirical
take on the original,
which you've watched,
and it's sort of like a self-aware,
version of the show that we all love.
And season two is just
like a whole another level.
I mean, we kind of have
like this like weird mystery
element, which is very fun,
- Ooh OK
- Like a little story to follow this year,
which is exciting.
And then just getting to see
like all the OGs coming back.
Lark Voorhies, who kills
it, and like everyone else,
which is awesome.
So, think it will be fun
- [Kelly] so wait, did you
watch any of the reruns?
Cause I just have a question.
It's a very serious Saved
by the Bell question.
Are you more Zack Morris or AC Slater?
- I'm such a Zack Morris.
- [Kelly] Okay, Zack Morris.
- Are you kidding me?
- [Kelly] Okay, okay, okay.
- Yeah, literally, Mario can like shut up.
Just kidding.
- Yeah, I loved
I loved both, but I was fascinated
that he always came out
in the wrestling uniform.
AC slater
- Zack Morris is beautiful
- And I was like, OK AC
Slater in your spandex.
- He's like the funny
(audience claps and cheers)
Here's the annoying thing about him.
He still looks like Mario Lopez
still looks like that.
What fountain has he found?
I don't know
- Mario is bionic
- It's crazy and Rude.
So wait, you're a producer on this show,
which is awesome.
So as a trans person,
like how has that helped with
telling authentic stories?
- Yeah, I mean, well,
and so like when the
show was brought to me,
it was like, obviously
very exciting opportunity,
but I felt that it was like
super important that if it was
gonna like step away from the school
and then tell this story in like the most
authentic way possible,
that the only way I could do
that is obviously, you know,
have some sort of
representation on both sides of
the camera, not just in front of it.
And that producer role,
I feel like allows us to tell
more of an authentic story
because there wasn't any
trans representation among,
the producers.
And I feel like because of it,
it's more entertaining
and it's more interesting
and it's more, like I said, authentic.
- It's more diverse, yeah.
- It's inspiring
- Thank you.
- So inspiring
It's important.
It's important that we don't
only just, diversify our cast,
but also the people telling the stories,
which is awesome that I get to do it.
(Audience Clapping)
- I think it's so cool
- Do you have a desire to do behind
the scenes as well as on camera?
- Yeah.
- Yes definitely I'm-
- She's like like boom, all the way.
- Yeah I'll take your boom any day
( giggling over )
- Um I'm a producer and Emily
too, which is really exciting.
- So cool.
- I didn't that that's something
you really want to pursue.
- Yes.
I love all aspects of the industry
and I've always wanted to create
stories from the ground up
- Yeah
- And be involved in all
aspects.
- Even when I wasn't asked to be,
I would always try to
be involved in some way
- Yeah I love that
Now I just love having the
title that allows me to feel
like I actually can.
But, I feel like with season two,
having had the experiences in season one
of being able to give,
be given the gift of critical
and creative criticism
and taking that and going, okay,
what can we do to be better,
to do better?
[Kelly] Right.
- We made it a really big point
to also diversify in it
and include more in front of the camera
[Kelly] Which Is Important
as well as behind with,
our crew and the creators
and the storytellers.
So, I really do think it's
like you said to, to say again,
like it's so important to have diversity
and inclusion be a part of--
- On our friends
- [Kelly] Representation, yeah absolutely
(clapping)
- [Josie] And by the way,
you know, it's so funny.
I,it just, just came to my head.
I didn't even think of it before,
when they asked if we know each other,
we don't know each other,
but one of your writers,
like taught a class of mine in college
- Oh really?
- Her name is Robin
- Oh yeah!
- [Josie] Yeah like Robin,
fully taught like in COVID.
- So cool.
- [Josie] Isn't that so random?
- I know Robin too. That's so cool
that we all know Robin I know Robin too.
I'm just kidding.
(overlapping).
- It's a small world.
Here's the best.
- Part though,I love about this.
What just happened is like we
do like a panel show, right?
And like you think people
don't know each other,
but it's such a small world.
Not even just like celebrities,
like there'll be a
non-celebrity be like, oh yeah,
they worked with our organization.
It's the craziest coolest thing.
And that's what we love
about the panel here is that
that happens.
- I'm going to start
parking in your spot now.
(audience claps and cheers)
Anyone is welcomed to
mine if I'm not in it.
- You an park in mine
if your down to hike,
it's like running.
- Here's why they probably
gave me that spot too not
because I'm like famous or
that's just cause they were like,
she drives a huge truck and
there's no where to put it.